de vuelta a Ciudad del Cabo en su propia
catedral el arzobispo Desmond tutú
tendrá un último adiós en la misma
edificación religiosa donde lideró su
lucha contra el apartheid abogando por
la libertad la democracia y el amor
entre los sudafricanos
desde su fallecimiento el pasado fin de
semana a los 90 años la Nación le ha
rendido tributo
líderes de una docena de religiones se
reunieron en un servicio interreligioso
el miércoles llamando a continuar el
legado de tolerancia del arzobispo tutú
defendió la justicia e incluso después
de que recibiéramos la libertad ya sea
en el cena o cualquier partido político
cuando siente que se está haciendo mal
se levantó como un verdadero líder y eso
es el verdadero liderazgo
todos de todo este residentes hasta el
alcalde de Johannesburgo compartieron su
admiración por Desmond tutú y su viuda
solían compartir un plato de comida con
mi madre Mantoux solía venir a casa y
como el moro con mi madre en realidad no
eran elevados no siempre fueron humildes
para mostrar su amor a la comunidad